fusion also from England asks how do you
decide the characters that get to be a
POV character I read somewhere you
resisted adding a character as a POV for
a while until finally giving in so when
did the kind of decisions you have to
make in that regard are there certain
traits that a POV character needs or do
they just need to be surviving well I
try to give each of my POV characters a
story and I've had an occasional people
character who any last chapter and then
dies so in that case it's a very short
story but it's uh it's nonetheless a
story it should have you know the
semblance of a beginning a middle and
end even if it's not connected to the
main story of the books it should have a
certain you know Rosencrantz and
Guildenstern are dead sort of thing I
mean that was their story which is off
to the side of Hamlet's story but both
part of the larger story I try to resist
having POV characters who are just there
to be a pair of eyes you know if the
battle is taking place or someone is
being murdered and I don't have a POV
character there to see it I tend to
present that as a report that someone
receives or a rumor rather than just
switching into third Guardsman and the
left it so I can so I can have him see
that because I don't like that as a
reader and I don't like that as as a
writer but one of the criteria is so so
I guess one criteria is do they have a
story and what is what is the story of
the POV character another thing though
is the thing of pair of eyes I mean
sometimes you need the question is it
important to present this thing on stage
to dramatize it and have the reader
actually go through it or is it
sufficient that we just hear about it
here is summary do you need full
dramatization or a summary narrative
sufficient and if we need this the scene
to be brought out and we may need a POV
character there and can I get any of my
existing POV characters there I mean
I've talked way those of you who read my
my not a blog will know that with dancer
dragons one of the things that I
wrestled with for a long time was what I
called the Meereenese knot which I can't
go into in any great detail without
spoiling tremendous things but a lot and
you know five years from now maybe when
if the next book is out or something and
everybody has read this book I can I
will talk more about that in more detail
but a lot of it simply had to do with
the number of POV characters being
together and some important events
coming on which some of them would would
see from one viewpoint some from another
and someone really know what was going
on
so how did I get these particular
sequence of events across with what
point of view and I would I would write
something from one point of view and it
wouldn't quite work so I'd write it from
a different point of view and I wouldn't
work either and I'd try splitting it you
know I solved that problem in in in part
by introducing a new point of view who
was much more centrally located but he
bit a character had been there all along
and he was deeply involved in the things
and he was me it won't fell into place
once I introduced that so you can have
that kind of breakthrough but I do need
to kill a lot more my point of view
characters because there have gotten to
be an awful lot of them but so which
ones will die well you didn't have to
keep reading to find it out